[Música]
[Aplausos]
o pessoal devido a mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um bo e
internacional como este aqui e quando
acordo de manhã minha idéia era que o
organismo internacional vou te ensinar o
peso vulgar aerodinâmica é o voar mais
longe o problema foi que quando eu fui
testar as minhas versões todas que eu
fiz não dava um jeitinho sempre na
experiência e agora você já está a
portar-se bem mas por que não vai
comentar lá fora o problema é que tá
chovendo bastante se o furor quando está
a chover número vai cair no chão vai
ficar todo molhado então não dava pra
lançado do novo enem foi ok para não
ficar sem vídeo já que o tempo não vai
melhorar nos próximos tempos vão ensinar
como fazer isso manda aqui depois vou
para fora quando o tempo estiver bom vou
testá los todos sofrer algo que vou
mesmo vai então eu vou fazer outro visa
ensinar como fazer um buraco ou mais do
que o tradicional
então vamos começar por fazer este
projecto vão precisar de uma folha de
tamanho a4 que são aquelas normais de um
professor é a primeira coisa que tem que
fazer e do grau ao mais só por este
canteiro um em cima do outro o dedo
indicador seguro lugar seguro em
destilarias e se isto estiver bem
alinhado o resto vai naturalmente como
vocês estão vendo agora fazer um buraco
precisamos só de uma parte ou seja como
a folha conseguiu fazer dois buracos e
agora temos que resgatar estão manhã
então cortar se inscreverem resgatem de
vincar várias vezes mas eu vou usar uma
tesoura porque acho que fica melhor
caiu agora está por fazer procurando
mais tá é só ganhar isto e agora vamos
começar a fazer o prouni próprio nem
pita cair nos braços da mãe
lula está falando
eu estou aqui com o indicador agora há
que conjugar um espumante com cuidado em
casa tudo bem vocês vão ouvir muitas e
muitas vezes nem tem muito bem mas em
tudo que seja papel é importante fazer
isso conhecer para marcar banho posição
em que agora vamos dobrar esta parte
para lino santo mas num ponto carga
primeiro centro vai ficar manicômio
interina do centro para este lado aí
isso é muito importante deixar esta
distância porque se nós quisermos mesmo
em cima da linha do centro para
problemas mais para frente vamos aqui no
inter quase na linha
eu não tenho a cabeça frente para nos
certificar de que está tudo bem a pele
tamanho
agora vou ver se consigo acertar assim
de longe
encaro pai e tenho que fazer a mesma
coisa por este lado que vou virar pra
mim é mais fácil pra mim ter a cabeça de
novo e acho que está bom vou brincar
agora vai
vocês conseguem ver é que essa distância
aqui eu me sinto um aviso importante o
outro lado vou virar assim e vou dobrar
ou mais
[Música]
como esquerda surgem aqui e veja o
estado começa a dobrar o papel até então
de ter um dedo que pelo maio e puxar pra
nós puxamos e depois é que nós ligamos
também brincar mãe o que é um pouco mais
difícil para o papel já começar a pular
várias camadas
vamos fazer dois triângulos mas é muito
importante esta para ficar em cima desta
para a equipe ou seja temos que segurar
com a mão aqui
enquanto fazemos cremos veiculado que
então eu vou segurar como esquerda e
como diretor fazer o primeiro triângulo
até no par a linha do centro
[Música]
já estava com o emprego faz um
foi então que se passa com a minha voz
aí vou fazer outro treino neste lado
agora vou mudar as mãos com segurar
qualquer ataque e conseguiram fazer um
triângulo
[Música]
agora vocês têm que ter alguns destes de
cooperación que a gente acaba rápido na
minha garganta está a ficar um pouco
estranha
vou ver agora os triângulos sobre isto e
agora estão do meu lado direito então
vocês façam igual eu estou a fazer agora
um só o lado direito e vamos verificar
temos aqui um quadrado e depois tem que
uma cruz me mais do que nós vamos fazer
agora nos próximos passos e vincar
estejam no início parecia mais fácil
próximo passo que vem pois encaramos as
meninas até então a primeira coisa assim
a linha de maio do quadrado e vamos
ajudar esta parte
igualzinho para não se perder e vamos
brincar estas linhas agora para fora
[Música]
já estão com as linhas puras vincadas
agora vão voltar para a posição que
estávamos antes é só virar de novo agora
muita atenção a cair até para o mais
difícil do buraco
estamos aqui a mão direita e o dedo do
maio eu vou colocar por trás desta linha
central já está feito agora com estes
dois dedos aqui com o indicador cpo
lugar eu vou pôr o publicador aqui mesmo
perto em um lugar neste aberto esse
texto lado do quadrado caiu de vez em
quando eu espero que começa já a ganhar
uma certa forma que lhe deixa assim
impressionado e 42 meses tem que pegar
nisto canto em cima eu vou fazer novo
porto isto pode dar problemas para
muitos de vocês e talvez não tenha
ficado bem informada
então pronto primário vão ter que o dedo
em maio por trás da linha que estamos no
início agora um indicador num canto
empolgado outro lado e é só apertar os
dois dedos
nós temos que manter esta linha aqui com
cima desta linha quintal ou deslizar
para o água vai mais mais ou menos
naturalmente a cair quando vocês pegarem
no bico vai ser muito fácil
depois de brincar mas vamos ter algo
deste tipo podem reparar que temos uma
uma faixa deste lado temos duas faixas
deste lado aqui então nós agora vamos
puxar isto para ficar mais ou menos como
aqui então vamos fazer assim desta forma
de dobrar e vejam quando eu dobrei isso
pra baixo formou um bolso que destitua
isso você é muito importante porque vai
permitir uns vai permitir que nós
faremos isso para dentro a cair agora do
pra isto
nesta parte que entrar dentro do bolso
caí com muito cuidado
vamos empurrar dito vai dobrar não vai
ficar assim muito bonito e para instruir
mesmo lá profunda ou seja o campinense
será mesmo que no cantinho e leves e
deve ser negro não se explicar melhor o
que tem que ficar mesmo é que é tocar
neste cantinho
eu vou usar este bonito mas vocês não
tiverem um político pode usar um lápis
só quer e com pontas só empurrar até
chegar à posição certa explicou
e vamos para o mar e tudo acontecer
agora parece que está tudo bem
para finalizar temos que fazer é que uma
espécie de triângulo aqui e o triângulo
aqui ok
isso vai permitir também fechar isto
para não ficar assim em aberto você
lançarem agora não vai funcionar agora é
ter em atenção que isto é uma porta
aberta e outra fechada para partida
aberta está virada para mim e vou fazer
um triângulo desta forma
[Música]
ninguém bairro
e desdobra entre os triângulos
agora temos aqui duas folhas tutela que
essas duas camadas papel aqui duas
camadas troféus aqui uma delas
vamos abrir empurrar isso pra dentro vai
cobrir impor pra dentro e faz assim uma
espécie de bolsa que também e esta parte
aqui que não fez nada vou colocar dentro
desta quarta foi dobrar assim que temos
bons e vamos manter esse tempo para
dentro
[Música]
é só fazer assim já foi ficou trancado
vamos fazer a mesma coisa país lado mas
aqui ele gera um efeito então parto tem
abertura está virada para mim de novo
vou fazer um triângulo desta forma
[Música]
agora o que de frente neste lado nós
temos aqui só uma camada de papel em um
estado aqui uns três camadas e nós não
conseguimos fazer um gol se usando esta
parte eu tenho uma chamada como fazer
obrigatória muito lado em três camadas
placar
então vamos abrir temporariamente para
tempo
[Música]
fazer nome pra você ver quem está assim
houve a proposta prevê exportar já está
agora a fazer como fizemos a crise
pessoal não ter visto para dentro do gol
[Música]
já está feito passa algumas vezes por
cima para ficar tudo direitinho e agora
conseguir voltar como lançar eu até
então para lá e agora parte mais
divertida que lançaram mulher e vejam
tem dois lados não tem uma linha nem
sempre você consegue ver facilmente no
outro lado tem uma faixa atravessada na
outra vamos virar com para que tenha
linha no meio para a frente e temos aqui
o nosso lugar nos por nelinha
depois o indicador nos por por trás aqui
e vamos cobrar pelo ponto acima do
bumbum ainda antes de lançar nós temos
que puxar o bom humor ainda assim desta
forma assim a tocar aqui e depois nós
vamos sim cut/al desta forma eu é muito
importante vocês saberem quando largar o
burnley então é a altura certa e vocês
vão chegar à instância máxima e depois é
só puxar um pouquinho para trás depois
largam a cair não larga distância mas
tem que ser ligeiramente para trás disse
charlie sheen muito para trás vai fazer
com cubo branco em branco o buraco
começou a girar aqui a gente vai fazer
se bem porque ele é mais fácil perceber
o que começa a gerar por isso puxar para
trás ou lançar pra frente eu não gira ok
então eu vou experimentar fazer aqui ver
se consigo mas tem lusa volta não sei se
isso vai voltar
voltou a ricoh vai tentar mais uma vez
vai custear o lancei mais ou menos para
o el al sham caiu o excelente mais
próxima para evitar a luz mas lança em
paralelo o chão porque eu sozinho vai
levantar por cima
agora vejam mais alguns lançamentos e
talvez vocês percebam melhor como fazer
isso eu sei que moram queria apanhar
mais ou menos uns 20 minutos vocês
mantêm várias vezes vocês vão perceber o
que funciona eo que não funciona é isso
[Música]
e pronto só os ganhos no fim eu espero
que vocês tenham gostado deste projeto é
que agora estou a fazer dois projetos
mais um que é mais complicada e um que é
muito mais simples a cair em algumas
estão de algum projeto é só deixar nos
comentários sobre a decisão até a
próxima
vamos lançar todas as mulheres ao mesmo
tempo não foi bom mas eu tentei